for a while I wanted to wear a leather
coat you know because I thought that'd
really be great you know but I felt
guilty about someone having to go out
and kill an animal you know just so I
could wear a leather coat and I made a
compromise for a while I was wearing a
live cow
that holds up no it does hold up that
was Steve Martin performing stand up 50
years ago look at you Steve since then
he starred in dozens of projects from
Father of the Bride love that too only
murders in the building love that too
now he's releasing an audiobook with his
friend of more than 30 years that's New
Yorker writer Adam gopnick it's called I
love this title so many Steves it
features their conversations about the
mini Steve's like Steve the actress
Steve the banjo player Steve the
comedian Steve The Collector it's great
here they are talking about when Steve
left stand up
the strangest thing for me was in my
latter days of stand-up it was the least
creative I have ever been
at the same time you were playing
stadiums and right to come up with
something new and try to work it in
there was no vehicle for it to get it in
to try it try a little thing when you're
in a club you could try something and
move on and going and change the subject
but there every word was Amplified on a
mic it had to be solid had to be heard
had to be delivered you were really at
the end there doing rock concerts yeah
it was
yeah if I had understood that I would
have been better off because I kept
thinking I'm doing a comedy show you
know I want them to laugh not cheer
only on CBS morning Steve Martin and
Adam gopnick join us here in the studio
welcome to you both thank you thank you
for having us first of all well that was
one of my favorite episodes because here
you are with the audience going yes a
Martin and you're sitting here thinking
this is not fulfilling to me because I
know I'm not as creative as I can be I
was surprised to hear you say that
well I had worked on an act for
essentially 18 years yeah and you know
when you get to that point you've got it
together and it's working you don't
really want to mess with it and yet your
creative mind wants to to move on to
something else and plus there's there's
the tired Factor that's
because I knew everything else that
Steve had done after that right and
obviously there had been some kind of
impulsion in him as there is in every
creative person not to be satiated by
repetition but you know what was
fascinating too Steve is that you said
you actually had to learn to be friendly
that you were an introverted person that
people Tommy Smothers once said this
about you like
Tommy's mother said it I didn't talking
to Steve Martin is like sitting in a
room alone yeah well that's true
and it still is by the way more than
ever
um but did you have to well early on I
was kind of isolated withdrawn and shy
and then when I started working with
Carl Reiner as a movie director I could
observe him because he was out go he was
outgoing in exactly the right way yeah
and he'd say that someone says can can
you uh blah do this and you go you just
watch me he'll say something like that a
little funny and it was just a way to
interact with the world that was my
biggest takeaway actually because when
Steve told me that the secret was be
like Carl Ryan I said I'm going to be
like Carl reinert as well and you start
and so we should all be like Carl Ryan
Yes uh when it comes to doing other
things though you move from Comedy into
acting and you're thinking at the time
this is going to be easy I've done
sketch right stage work well there's a I
did I I had been on stage I've done
sketches on television I've written
sketches so I thought well acting is
just you know and then the like first
day on the set oh yeah I had to go you
know I had to
sit down and put a go so do I but the
cup when do I put the cup down I see you
know and uh the script said put down the
cup and you're like yeah
yeah so there's a
eventually after years you learned just
to put it down like a little person and
then it works it works in particular
when you write the scripts you have this
great line about how if you want to make
five great movies you've got to make 40
movies well a a movie is a behemoth
and you can have the best director the
best actors the best script and
everything and somehow it doesn't work
and and and also can work you just don't
know and it's such an opera that you
can't predict if it's really going to be
good and is that what's up to from being
in these feature films over the last
handful of years
no and no I mean it is a pressure like
just you want it to work and there's so
much uh pressure on around it took
financially and the crew and the cast of
course the studio uh
but it's always a relief to come here
and just have fun yeah you know and do
something like with Adam where we're
just talking and then we later edit it
well that's what I think is so
interesting about the two of you you've
been friends for over 30 years Adam you
say in the in the in the podcast
audiobook that you all bonded over his
passion for art which you call his prime
passion yeah yeah we met at an at an
artication I had curated a show at the
Museum of Modern Art actually and Steve
and I met and we started talking about
it and Steve's passion for art was I
think in a certain way uh uh the kind of
Salvation in other words it was
something yeah so something very private
I could enjoy myself as not public yeah
but I would read Adam uh you don't write
about art so much anymore but when he
was writing about art I always felt oh
I'm smarter now I'm smarter now and and
it wasn't difficult it wasn't art speak
it was graspable what he was talking
about that friendship lead to this
because number one I have to say the
podcast is so well done you're riding
your bike from the East side right Steve
lives and you two just sit and talk
again we've agreed to call it an audio
books
I hope we're not live it just was it
just was fun Steve and I have been
having conversations in different
countries for a long time and I would
truly ride my bike over and we would
start talking and we discovered what our
subjects were as we were talking about
them and one of the things we talked
about was writing that Steve has has
written and written novels that's what I
do and writing is just the opposite of
movie making because
um nobody cares and nobody invests in it
at all so you have to be free nobody you
know it doesn't cost 17 million dollars
Steve you've talked about your
fascination with magic yeah yeah and you
can see in your early stand up some of
the influence of magicians that have
that have made um that may have been
part of your life growing up what about
magic kind of helped create and mold you
well there's a great thing about when
you're a kid and you want to be in Show
business and Magic you can go buy a
trick you buy a trick you read the
instructions and it even gives you
patter says hi I just you know came back
from Egypt and got this magic thing so
you're already in show business and you
just can do your tricks yeah get used to
performing uh and so it's a good and
it's fun yeah the Showmanship of it Adam
what's so interesting about Steve it
seems to me is that most people that
feeling of not being good at acting on
day one is a frightening feeling and you
don't go back to it but you so many
times in your career have sought out
that new thing and then ascended it do
you know anyone like that yeah no I
think one of the things that makes Steve
Steve the answer is no yeah sorry no
nobody other than anybody has that but
no I do think it's true that every that
um interesting people tend to want to do
the next thing try you know you know
magicians have this beautiful term the
real work and they mean people who have
got great technical virtuosity but who
also are idiots syncretically themselves
and that's very much what I like is that
there are so many Steves and they're all
knocked out and they're all fantastic
and you have you both captured it very
well this is one of your products and
you're also working on the Mastery I
have a book out called the real work on
the mystery of Mastery which is kind of
transitive with everything we talk about
by the way I I judge audiobooks by how
many calories you can lose so this is a
400 500 calorie all right
thank you you can download the so many
Steves I love that title audiobook right
now after you're done watching CBS
that's right that's right we'll be right
back